spécialisée dans le café en grains mr
bean travaille en partenariat avec les
as tu vu ce qu'avait fait depuis 2013 la
société de torréfaction installé un
atelier sur place à andrésy le but
s'engager pour l'insertion des personnes
en situation de handicap au début les
attaques commencé à conditionner nos
cafés ensuite ils ont fait notre
plateforme logistique et depuis presque
quatre ans maintenant on a installé
notre nouveau torréfacteur à lézat de
gustave eiffel du coup depuis le café
vert jusqu'à l'expédition chez nos
clients en passant par la torréfaction
tout est fait pour nos collègues les
travailleurs en situation de handicap au
total ils sont une dizaine à travailler
avec mr bean chacun prépare les
commandes s'occupe du conditionnement et
de la tour des factions rosol de grandes
toques ap et en fait on le cuit en fait
avec la mention de la littorale dans cet
atelier il travaille le grand une
vingtaine d'heures par semaine objectif
être au coeur du métier c'est vrai que
du café on
on n'avait jamais fait
donc c'était un beau challenge de
pouvoir travailler sur des produits
alimentaires
et de deux de faire découvrir sa à
chacun l'intérêt c'est aussi
l'utilisation des machines donc accéder
à la technique et bien sûr faire
respecter toutes les règles de sécurité
par rapport à thématique aujourd'hui les
accusés avaient pelle conditions entre 3
et 4 tonnes de café par mois
[Musique]